josh bolten via habitat 67 depuis plus
de 40 ans une véritable histoire d'amour
mon épouse travaille m expo et puis on
lui notre premier dit au théâtre expos
mais vous la journée au monde en avril
ouvrant la porte de l'appartement
on a presque fondu partir de ce moment l
os c'était le paradis cause
moi je pense que ça allait ajouter des
années note l'exposition universelle de
montréal a été une vitrine sur ce qui se
faisait mieux en art en architecture et
en design
il ya un avant et un après expo 67 pour
plein de raisons l'immigration
l'ouverture du québec sur le monde la
reconnaissance de montréal comme une
ville internationale c'est un événement
fascinant encore aujourd'hui qui a des
répercussions encore aujourd'hui
originaire d'israël moshe safdie est
arrivé à montréal à l'âge de 15 ans il a
fait sa maîtrise et sa thèse à
l'université mcgill avant de signer à 25
ans habite à 67 son premier projet au
sortir de ses études
c'était le début d'une carrière
internationale avec son projet
visionnaire le jeune ingénieur rêver à
l'habitation du futur c'est à dire
comment on vit bien dans une zone qui
est densément peuplées on essaie
d'utiliser l'eau de chaleur on essaie
d'avoir une vie communauté des espaces
en commun ce qui était pas très présent
à l'époque
véritable bijou architectural moi
j'essaie d'y a conçu son complexe de 148
d'appartements comme on sculpte une
oeuvre d'art lorsqu'on a un complexe on
voit des choses
les images sont encadrés par la
structure alors une journée le voir où
j'en ai fait beau soleil journée on a un
bateau devant nous ça change c'est une
obsession de la beauté de l'étude à
l'origine habitat 67 accueille les
visiteurs de l'expo offerts sur le
marché de la location comme appartements
abordables jusqu'au milieu des années 80
le complexe était transformé en
copropriété et les prix n'ont cessé de
s'envoler au fil des ans plusieurs
personnalités québécoises comme bernard
de rome marie saint pierre danielle
ouimet ou rené homier roy y ont habité
ce fut également le décor d'un clip de
leonard cohen ou encore d'une séance
photos de céline dion habitat 67 est un
domaine privé longtemps réservé aux
professionnels
des visites sont désormais ouvertes au
public sur réservation on est curieux de
voir cette bâtisse l'extérieur mais
d'avoir la chance de voir de l'intérieur
ces mages et moshe safdie affirmé
qu'elle avait raté son coup s'il fallait
ajouter les oeuvres d'art cette vision
là c'était fait pour tous on regarde à
lutter on est capable de faire une carte
postale avec la vue qu'on a pu je pense
que ça marche effectivement assez bien
ici nabi alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal